oh it's what's the question Donna that I
do truly love each other
we've been on speed boats we've been in
hot tubs I attended the wedding to his
lovely bride Casey and we do love each
other we love each other very much I
can't I can't lie you're gonna ask me if
it's ever crossed certain taboo lines
and I'm gonna say no it hasn't
[Music]
funny story about rowdy I tried to take
him home he was our dead taxidermied dog
the network wouldn't let me have him and
so they put him in a warehouse I picture
him like in in in Raiders of the Lost
Ark where they put the art in the back
of that warehouse with all those
precious relics that Rowdies in the back
of some Disney storage space like that
although I did ask them if I could put
him in in my film wish I was here it
happened to a cameo he's in the
background of one of the shots in which
I was here the studio literally thought
that I was gonna steal the dead
taxidermy - animal and they sent a
security guard with the dog who was his
bodyguard for the day because they were
right I would have steel in his ass in
going for the butterflies in the stomach
there's so many I don't even where to
begin I like the ones that were so
random and stoner II like Donald dressed
as a goat what do you call that when
someone's half a goat at half man and he
was trying to hit on I think he was
hitting on Keri Russell and I think I
and she was dressed as a mermaid and I
think I remember saying go turn
that's my mermaid I'm gonna go for the
wishbone because I think I can get it
budge
is that TT well we're not playing other
real rules Bill Lawrence our show's
creator thought the janitor might just
be a figment of JD's imagination Neil
who played the janitor didn't have a
major role in the show he was doing a
cameo in the pilot Neil was so
incredibly funny that bill made him a
regular and in terms of his name no one
no one knew his name
and I think bill pi think bill made that
up like last season and to this day
there's controversy over his name
whether it really is Glen Matthews we
don't know okay I'm going for the broken
heart
got it
[Music]
no but I often get asked by people and
they're not even like hitting they're
like you played a doctor for so long can
you look at this and I think they're
joking but they're not they think I
somehow have some sort of knowledge and
I just say put ointment on it no matter
what it is even if it's like a broken
arm appointment if you're listening out
there don't listen to my advice seek
medical help if you have a genuine
ailment but first try Orrin
one of the great things about the show
was that Bill Lawrence let us improvise
a lot we would always get what was it
was written you know locked down and
then we would like just play around and
that's where a lot of some of the
audience's favorite stuff over the years
came from just so many of anyone
watching who has a group of friends who
would just joke around and make each
other laugh and be stupid together
that's what we were doing and so a lot
of stuff like Eagle and all that some
people like we're just us like [ __ ]
around I got the wrenched ankle which
isn't gonna come out without a little
shake up but my friend Danica says
that's cheating I pitched a bill that JD
inherits a small amount of money and
that he uses it to make the doctor Acula
movie that he and Turk always dreamed of
making so that it would be like like a
TV movie or a small miniseries where
there's still doctors and their friends
but in their spare time they're
fulfilling their dream of making their
vampire medical indie film dr. Acula
please tweet bill lawrence @v Doozer
that you think it's a great idea because
he's on the fence about link to this and
say Zach's idea for the doctor Acula
movie is genius what's wrong with you
bill you know I'm gonna get the charley
horse the janitors wife had limited
fingers and she had used whatever
fingers she had to make me scrubs short
shorts and he wanted me to wear them and
he was very offended that I wasn't gonna
wear them in the hospital because she
had put all this time into making scrubs
short shorts and I had to get through
the line I'm a doctor I can't wear short
shorts to work and it's still to this
day makes me crack up and Neil just
looking at Neil's face it was really
really hilarious and you can see the gag
reel the zillion takes of me trying to
get through I could probably get the
funny bone the spare ribs are gonna be
tough
[Music]
the Todd the Todd's only real Ark was
that you learned that he didn't he would
have sex with anyone young old male
female anything he was down which I
think was a beautiful arc for him over
eight years I had the Adam's apple which
I'm gonna go for now because I have a
prominent one nice question it's now on
Comedy Central for two hours a day four
episodes a day five times a week I mean
I'm very surprised that it's the show
that keeps on going and going and going
that's pretty cool and it's a testament
to how much the fans love it and and and
so I'm super grateful for them
that there's no greater job than
laughing your ass off with your friends
all day long I spent eight and a half
years laughing with my best friends and
then hearing that we were making people
around the world laugh I was so blessed
out of that that great awesome job and I
just love that it made people so happy
can I get my nose hairs with this thing
Danika look away she plays by the
Hardcore rule don't let your kids eat at
home everybody